Daniel: Hello and welcome.
It's ActInf Lab Livestream 52.2 on March
9, 2023.
Welcome to the Active Inference
Institute.
We're a participatory online institute
that is communicating, learning, and
practicing applied active inference.
You can find more information on these
links.
This is a recorded and archive live
stream, so please provide feedback so we
can improve our work.
All backgrounds and perspectives are
welcome, and we'll be following video
etiquette for Livestreams head over
Active Inference.org to learn more about
getting involved with projects and
learning groups.
All right!
We are back in Livestream 52.2, in our
third discussion on the paper geometric
methods for sampling, optimization,
inference and adaptive agents.
We had a Dot-Zero background and context
video and last week Lance joined for
52.1, where we had a great overview
discussion on the paper.
So today we're going to see where it
goes, see where our last week has taken
us and how we're thinking about it or
curious about it.
If you're watching live, of course, feel
free to write questions in a live chat.
Otherwise, let us pick up on a mostly
blank slide.
And just thanks again, Lance, for
joining.
If you want to give any sort of
introduction or recap opening here, go
for it.
Lance: Well, yeah, I mean, thanks a lot,
Daniel, for organizing this.
I'm super happy to be here, I think.
Well, last time we went through most of
the paper, we discussed a lot about
sampling.
I guess the idea of sampling.
We discussed a bit less about Hamiltonia
Monte Carlo, which is one of the, I
guess, state of the art methods for
sampling in continuous space.
We discussed a lot about optimization.
There's a nice figure actually that we
can discuss today which gives some nice
intuition about the kind of optimization
methods that we reviewed in the paper.
And then there's another section on
statistical inference.
So this is a bit of a different section
than people in the free energy principle
literature and active inference are used
to.
Because here the goal of inference is
about approximating expectations as
opposed to just approximating
distributions in of themselves.
It turns out to be these two perspectives
turn out to be dual.
But I guess here we want to develop
notions of divergences and discrepancies
that are a bit more general than the KL
divergence and that can use to solve
problems that the KL divergence cannot.
And I guess the overall picture for why
we want to do that is the Kale divergence
turns out to have a lot of really nice
properties that we can discuss.
One of them is that if the Kale
divergence is reduced, it means that the
two distributions in play are more
similar in terms of information.
So there is this idea of information
monotonicity where the KL divergence sort
of gives an ordering as to what extent
two distributions quantify.
So if you had three distributions and you
compute the KL divergence between them
and now KL of AB is lower than KL of AC.
It means that B is more closer in terms
of information to A than C is to A.
So you have this really nice thing that
is captured by the Kel divergence, which
makes sense when we're dealing with
information.
The Kel divergence also has so many other
nice properties.
It's not a distance, but it turns out to
behave a bit like a square distance.
So you have this kind of like, really
nice pitagorian theorem.
And I won't get into the exact statement,
but it's like if you have a B and C
distributions, then KLAB plus klac equals
KLBC.
If you have like a rectangle triangle, if
ABC defines a rectangle triangle in
information space, you have other
properties like the KL divergence gives
and so on.
So the KL divergence is in general, I
would say, the distribution, the
divergence of choice.
But it turns out that in many cases you
just can't use it.
For example, when you have samples and
you want to approximate some samples with
a distribution, then the Kale divergence
just is not going to work there.
So you need to derive some other things.
So this is to say that we're considering
statistical inference a bit more
generally than what we do in active
inference in general.
And so this speaks to why the section
here is a bit different from the standard
inference literature that we usually
consider.
And then I think that the well, then this
section five, which is about active
inference, and I think we should discuss
that a little bit more because the
formation active inference lab that's
presented there is to my mind the most
general and also the simplest
conceptually that's been out there.
I mean, we sort of recap the derivation
active inference lab and also like the
properties of the expected community
properties of active inference and also
how to scale active inference and so on.
And we do that in just seven pages or
five pages.
I mean, it's just very short.
So it stands, sure, but it's like a
really concise summary.
And actually from there you can really
derive a lot of technical papers.
Active inference lab, to me, it's the
most general, and if you as a reader can
understand that section, then you can
sort of really understand what active
inference is about.
This is kind of the overview for today.
I would really like to be discussing
questions because last time we read
discussed about most of the papers.
But yeah, whatever comes up.
Daniel: Awesome.
All right, great.
Well, let us talk about some of the more
foundational pieces hamiltonian Monte
Carlo and then on through section four
with the points that you raised about the
KL, which generalized inference beyond
how it may have been brought up in other
octave.
And then we can spend most of the time in
section five and looking at some of those
figures connecting some of the intuitions
about the ball rolling down the bowl to
the person running.
So.
Lance: Sounds good on Hamiltonian?
Daniel: Monte Carlo.
Where do you want to pick up?
Lance: Sure.
I meantonian so last time we discussed a
lot about the problem of sampling and why
that's the difficult problem.
And we arrived at the conclusion, or I
presented like Monte Carlo methods, how
they work.
So you're basically running a stochastic
process, like a random motion and sort of
the distribution defining the process is
going to convert your target
distribution, which means that when you
run the process long enough, then every
point that it's going to be in is going
to be like a sample of the distribution
that you want to sample from.
Now, there's a lot of issues with that.
Conceptually, it's not so difficult, but
actually, when you want to implement this
in practice, it turns out to be really
hard because if you just implement the
simplest stochastic process to sample
your target distribution, it's going to
be extremely slow.
And I think that's the main bottleneck
when developing Monte Carlo methods.
Monte Carlo sampling in general is slow.
And that's also one of the reasons why
one might want to do variational
inference instead of sampling.
So something is slower, but it's also
more accurate.
It can approximate distributions that are
completely arbitrary.
So if you care about accuracy and you
have time and computational resources,
then for sure go for sampling.
If you care about speed, about doing
things online, and you don't care about
accuracy so much, then the variational
inference is the way to go.
At least that's my understanding right
now.
So let's say you wanted to sample a
distribution in a continuous space.
So it could be just as last time.
Let's imagine the state space is the desk
where I'm at, and you sort of have the
distribution, which could be like
multimodal, very weird, and you just want
to take samples from there.
HamiltonI Monte Carlo is probably the
state of the art methods method to do
that.
There's a lot of other methods out there,
but Hamilton Monte Carlo typically just
works very well and in a wide variety of
situations.
Instead, the idea of HamiltonI Monte
Carlo is you're going to augment the
state space with so let's say that the
original state space you start with are
the positions.
And so you're going to a mend that with a
velocity state space.
If your original state space was
Euclidean space of N dimensions, you just
end up with a nuclear space of two N
dimensions.
So you double the size of the state
space.
And now you say, okay, well, the
distribution that I want to stumble from
actually defines an energy landscape.
So technically it's like if you have
distribution which is P, then minus lock,
p is an energy landscape.
So points where minus lock P is low are
points where P is high.
And so these are points that you want to
sample a lot from.
And contrary wise, if minus Lock t is
very high, then P is low.
And you don't really want to go there so
much because these are points of low
probability.
So I think this minus log P, actually
there's many reasons why minus Lock P is
meaningful in physics.
But just note for now that minus Lock P
is just like a function and the minimum
of the functions of that function are the
high probability points and these are
high energy points where you basically
don't want to go there so much.
So let's call this minus Lock P potential
energy.
And so this is what this really is in
physics.
Technically in physics, P would be a
gives measure, what people call an
equilibrium distribution.
Last time we saw like soft max, minus
something.
The something is the potential energy
anyway.
And so minus Lock P would be the
potential energy.
And then if you add kinetic energy on
your velocities, then you get what's
called a Hamiltonium, which is the sum of
the potential and kinetic energies.
So what is exactly kinetic energy?
The kinetic energy is like velocity
squared pretty much.
So if you add remember that your state
space is position and velocity.
If you add and you take a point in state
space, so you would have kinetic energy,
which is velocity squared, and a
potential energy which would be minus
lock peak.
Now, if you add the two together, what
you get is a Hamiltonian, which is the
sum of the kinetic energy and potential
energy.
And this is just standard physics.
Hamiltonian is the sum of kinetic and
potential energy and it gives us the
total energy of the system.
So why we start with the problem of
sampling.
And here I just told you something very
complicated where we get a Hamiltonian,
there's actually a good reason why I want
to do that.
And it comes back to the idea of
geometric integration that we talked
about last time, which is that typically
maybe I have a process that I know will
give very efficient sampling, but
actually when I implement it on the
computer in discrete time, I just lose
all the properties that make that
sampling efficient.
So actually it turns out that most people
working in Monte Carlo sampling, they're
working on efficient discretizations of
continuous processes as opposed to on the
continuous process themselves.
Really the bottleneck.
And the difficulty here is the
implementation part, implementing process
on a computer like you and I had in such
a way that we retain all the good
sampling properties.
So one very powerful idea is that of
geometric integration, which is of
preserving geometric properties of a
system.
Geometric integration is the field that
develops computational methods of
numerical integration and numerical
discretion in such a way that they
preserve important geometric properties
of the system.
Here, the geometry in play is a
Hamiltonian.
And so you might think, well, that's
pretty weird.
I mean, a Hamiltonian is an energy here
we're talking about preserving the
geometry and preserving the Hamiltonian.
How do these two things fit together?
And so it turns out that the presence of
a Hamiltonian and the fact that we have a
state space that has positions and
velocity, technically, in mathematics,
what we then get is what people call
symptom geometry.
So symptom geometry just arises when we
have those states that comprise positions
and velocity and where you have
Hamiltonians.
So this is just like a way of explaining
why the Hamiltonian is closely and
intimately related to geometry.
So geometry integration enables you to
discrete processes in such a way that the
Hamiltonian is preserved.
Now, when you think about the
Hamiltonian, the Hamiltonian gives you
the energy of a particular point in
space.
And so if you simulate trajectories that
preserve the Hamiltonian, what you're
effectively doing is sampling from the
contours of the probability distribution,
contours that have the same probability.
So basically going around, let's say, for
example, in circles in a region that has
the same probability, when we want to
sample, we want to go everywhere.
I mean, we want to sample regions of high
probability, low probability, and want to
be able to go from one to the other.
So what geometric integration allows us
to do is to simulate dynamics that are
going to preserve the contours of the
probability distribution, and they're
going to do so very well.
The advantage here is that when we use
geometric integration to simulate
Hamiltonian dynamics, which are
conservative and again, staying the
contours, what geometric integration
allows us to do is to take time steps
that are very long.
So it enables us to travel very far in
the landscape while still preserving the
Hamiltonian.
So you don't need to take very small time
steps to remain accurate and preserve the
Hamiltonian.
But actually, dramatic integration allows
you to take very long time steps and
still preserve the Hamiltonian.
So now we have a dynamic that's
Hamiltonian preserving that's just very
good because you can take very long time
steps, and that enables you to go around
the contours of the probability
distribution.
So what you want to do next is to change
contours.
You want to go to contours that are of
high probability, contours of lower
probability.
And you want to do so in a way that the
contours of high probability are sampled
much more and much more often than the
contours of lower probability.
So what you do is that you augment your
Hamiltonian dynamic with what people call
a velocity refreshment or a momentum
refreshment.
And so this is how it works.
So you're going to simulate your
Hamiltonian dynamics for some time, and
then after a while, you're going to be
like, okay, well, now I'm going to change
the velocity at random by just drawing a
new velocity from a Gaussian
distribution.
And so by drawing a new velocity from a
Gaussian distribution, you're just going
to change contour completely.
And then there's what's called the
constraint that I just talked about,
which is you want to change contours of
the probability distribution in such a
way that contours of high probability are
visited much more often than contours of
low probability.
So you want to preserve that.
You want to do that in a way.
So the third ingredient of Hamiltonian
Monte Carlo comes in, which is
metropolis.
Hastings.
And so Metropolis Hastings is this accept
reject that we discussed briefly last
time.
And so Metropolis Hastings is just super
clever and it enables you to say it just
tells you whether this momentum
refreshing step is actually a good one or
a bad one and should be rejected.
A momentum refreshment is good if overall
your sampling is going to remain faithful
to the target distribution, but it is bad
if it remains unfaithful.
So actually running this metropolitate
things except rejects, that allows you to
change contours of the property
distribution in a way that remains
faithful to the target distribution.
And so there you go.
That's basically Hamiltonian Monte
Carlo.
So to recap, you a mental state space by
adding velocities.
This allows you to build the Hamiltonian
by declaring that the original
probability distribution gives you
potential energy and you add a kinetic
energy on the velocities, which is just
velocity squared.
Because you have a Hamiltonian, you can
use geometric integration to simulate
Hamiltonian dynamics very accurately and
with very long time steps.
The very long time steps is a crucial
thing because it means that with very low
computational costs, you can sample very
far.
So it means that you don't get stuck in a
region of the probability distribution,
but you can actually visit it much more
fast and efficiently.
So that's the first part.
The problem with those dynamics again, is
that they remain on the contour of the
probability distribution.
And so you want to sample the whole
So what you do is every once in a while,
and I think that's a hyper parameter in
your, in your sampling algorithm, let's
say every ten iterations of the
Hamiltonian dynamic, every ten time steps
of the Hamiltonian dynamic, you're going
to sample you're, you're just going to
randomly take a new velocity.
So you're going to change contour in the
probability distribution.
And the crucial point there is you want
to change contour in a way that's
faithful of the probability distribution
and that's faithful of the sampling
problem that you want to do.
There comes the last thing, which is
Metropolis Hastings, which ensures that
the momentum reflect freshman will be
good for sampling, I mean, will preserve
your target probability distribution.
So with that, you just get a very
efficient sampling algorithm.
And so it seems a bit convoluted, right?
And one bottleneck, of course, is that
you need to double the dimension of the
state space.
And if your state space is already
extremely large, that could be a
bottleneck.
It could be the case that actually
doubling the dimension to add velocities,
it could be a computational bottleneck.
So that's a problem, but still, in most
cases, that's not a problem.
Again, Hamilton in Monte Carlo is
convoluted.
But the overall take home message I would
want you to take from this is that it is
a method that remains faithful to the
probability distribution they want to
sample.
And this is crucial.
And it is also a method that through
geometric integration, it enables you to
take time steps that are very long and
still get accurate sampling.
So this is the really cool thing.
If you could come up with a whole bunch
of other methods that did not require to
double the dimension of the state space
or that didn't use geometric integration,
the problem that you would probably run
into is that the thing that you came up
with when you implemented in the
computer, it doesn't exactly preserve the
probability distribution that you want to
sample.
And so the problem with that is that this
would lead to biased sampling.
And biased sampling is like you're going
to sample a different probability
distribution, which might be just a bit
different, but still a different
probability distribution than what you
really want to sample.
And this would bias your predictions.
So the really cool thing of Hamiltonia
Monte Carlo is that you're actually able
to have unbiased sampling through the
Metropolis Hastings step.
And this is a crucial thing.
So it's computationally implementable in
general, there's no computational
bottlenecks apart from this doubling of
state space, and it leads to unbiased
sampling.
It's also relatively simple.
So this is why this is really used all
over the place.
There's another few perspectives that
might explain why it works so well.
So in the paper in the last subsection of
section two, which is about optimization,
so the action on optimization is about
how to accelerate optimization, how to
derive an optimization algorithm.
2.6.
That's the one.
So the whole thing about section two is
about deriving an optimization algorithm
that accelerated in a physical way.
And by accelerated, what I mean by
accelerated, it's not about just going
faster, but it's about having
acceleration, which means that if you go
slightly up in the paper on the figure, I
think this figure is great.
And by the way, I wasn't the one who came
up with this figure, but I think this
figure is great.
It really gives a lot of intuition for
what acceleration really is.
So if you look at the green cup, or I
know how you call this, the green well on
the left, this would be like a bowl
rolling down the well.
And the well is still that honey to like
a certain level.
And so there you get a lot of friction.
So your ball would just roll down very
slowly, and the speed of the ball would
be proportionate to the slope of the
well.
So this is not accelerated because
there's a lot of friction.
And so the speed is just proportional to
the slope of the well.
So this is actually what gradient descend
does.
But now if you go on the right, you get
what people coin physics on under the
hand system, which is also an accelerated
system, a system that's meaningfully
accelerated.
So if you replace the honey in the well
by some water, then there's going to be
way less friction and your bowl is
actually going to accelerate and
overshoot the minimum of the well and
then sort of stabilize.
But the point here is that this bulb is
just going to get so much faster to the
minimum.
This idea for optimization is just
extremely powerful.
And by the way, on the right hand side in
the graph, you can see the improvements
that you get when you implement these
sort of ideas.
So this was on a I'll come back to
sampling in a bit, I promise.
But this is actually very well, very
related.
You can see on the graph on the right
what kind of improvements you get when
you go from under damp, first order
system grade in the sense system, when
you go from an over damped first order
grade in the sense system to an underdamp
second order accelerated system.
And so you can see the curve, right?
So the black orange curve is over damp.
There's no acceleration.
It's very slow.
The last curve, the blue one, it's
accelerated and it's just super fast.
So you can see it sort of gives you like
quantitative data as to how many
improvements you can get by implementing
this acceleration in a physically
meaningful way.
Daniel: Could you just describe the axes
of the graph and also what the league
group is here?
Lance: The lead group is in the figure
legend.
In the fourth line, you see the leg group
is so n.
So that's technically that's the special
orthogonal group of dimensions n.
If I remember correctly, these are all
the matrices, all the square matrices of
size n by n that have a determinant equal
to one.
So the determinant is just like a
function where you give it a matrix and
it gives you a number.
The fact that the fact that the
determinant is equal to one means that
here we're just taking matrices which
are, which produce not translations, but
changes of coordinates that preserve the
geometry in a system.
Just to elaborate on this a little bit,
because for people who are not intimately
familiar with matrices, it might seem a
little opaque.
So when you have a matrix, a matrix can
multiply vectors.
So a square matrix takes in vectors of
side of dimension n and it outputs
vectors of dimension n by
multiplication.
So if you have a square matrix, it just
induces a transformation of your state
space because each vector, each point
which is a vector, gets converted into
another point which is another vector.
Now there's a lot of, I guess, properties
there, right?
You could have all sorts of translations
of state space or rotations in state
space or transformations of state space.
If the determinant of the matrix is equal
to one, it means that the transformation
of state space that the matrix induces
will preserve the geometry of the sixes.
It will preserve distances and it will
preserve crucially orientation as well.
Because if you only asked the determinant
to be equal to one or minus one, then the
matrix transformation would preserve the
geometry, but it would not preserve the
orientation.
It could mirror things.
So if you only asked the determinant to
be equal to one or minus one, you would
get a lead group that's called the
orthogonal group, which is usually
denoted O of N.
And here we require the determinant to be
just equal to one.
And so you get the special orthogonal
group.
And so it's this group of matrices that
have this property.
Now this is not really important for the
example here because you could have taken
any other lead group and got something
similar and got a similar difference in
performance.
I guess it's just interesting for its own
sake.
And so the graph though, the K is the
number of iterations.
So the number of time steps, so that's
the x axis and the y axis is how close
you are from the minimum.
And, and it's in lock scale.
So as you can see, the, the blue curve is
going to get like in 100 iterations, it's
going to get basically at ten to the
minus 410 to the minus five distance from
the minimum.
So it's like super, super close.
It basically gets there in 100 iterations
when you take the other normal gradient
descent methods where you see that it's
going to take so much longer.
So yeah, this is really the advantage of
using second order methods.
And what I mean by second order methods
is that by second order means that you
actually double the state space to
introduce velocities.
So that you not only have a dynamical
system over positions, but you have a
dynamical system of velocities.
And so it means that you have a physical
notion of acceleration because
acceleration is a movement of
velocities.
And so if you double the state space by
saying this is position, this is
velocities, and you see I have a motion
in this like a state space that's twice
as big, then you have a meaningfully, a
meaningful notion of acceleration.
And this is really powerful.
And so you can see already a parallel
here, which is that Hamiltonia Monte
Carlo also has this notion of
acceleration in some way, at least just
intuitively, because we also doubled the
size of the state space to introduce
velocities.
And so it turns out that this intuition
is actually you can make it into a formal
correspondence.
And I think this is something that quite
interests me, to be honest.
So if you remember, if we come back to
the intuition for sampling.
The intuition for sampling through Monte
Carlo methods is we have a target
distribution that we want to sample
from.
So we're going to run a dynamic, random
dynamic towards that distribution.
Now, what makes sampling efficient is
that the distribution that characterizes
the process because again the process is
random so that each time it is at a
random location that is characterized by
distribution.
What makes sampling efficient is that the
distribution characterizing the process
just converted as fast as possible to the
thing that you want to sample from.
This is to say that you can think of
sampling as an optimization on the space
of probability distributions.
You want to move your probability
distribution of the process as fast as
possible to your target.
And so you can see from there that
sampling is actually not so different
from variational inference.
It's just the same idea, only variational
inference.
You're typically going to take a
parameterized family of distributions and
approximate the targets, while here you
have a non parameterized family that's
given by your dynamic that's going to
perfectly match the target.
Again, with that, I want you to have the
take home message that sampling, you can
think about it as an optimization on the
space of probability distributions in the
sense that you have a target distribution
and you want to get there as fast as you
can with the process.
Now let's suppose, and so here is the
crucial connection between sampling and
optimization in the way that we've
described it here.
Let's suppose that you run this
accelerated optimization scheme on the
space of probability distributions then
the process.
So you would get the dynamic on the space
of probability distributions that has a
meaningful notion of acceleration through
the accelerated method that was shown
here.
So if you look at what kind of dynamic
this really gives you, it gives you a
process which is given by a stochastic
differential equation that is known as
under damp launch of a dynamic.
So there's an equation for it and I think
action subsection 2.8.
But the point is under dynamics is a
stochastic differential equation whose
density or probability distribution stole
this accelerated optimulation problem on
the space of probability distributions.
So just from there, you know that under
that logo on dynamics, it's going to be a
very efficient sampler because it
meaningfully accelerates and gets the
target, I mean, quite fast.
The problem is under label logo on
dynamics, you cannot simulate it
accurately.
Well, you can simulate it accurately, but
you cannot simulate it exactly on your
computer in practice.
So this comes back to the numerical
integration problem that we discussed
just before.
And so you have to find a way to
discretize or in other words implement
under dumpling bound dynamics on your
computer in such a way that you retain
that the thing that you implemented on
the computer retains this meaningful
notion of acceleration.
It turns.
Out that you can see Hamiltonian Monte
Carlo as a faithful numerical discretion
or numerical implementation of under damp
launcher and dynamics that's going to
preserve these acceleration properties
and therefore this efficient sampling.
So this is all like, yeah, a lot of
interesting connections.
But basically what I want to get at is
you really have this notion of
acceleration that permeates well, I guess
physics.
But here it permeates sampling and it
permeates optimization.
And so the method that was shown here
about optimization and Hamiltonian Monte
Carlo, they're just the same in a way.
Only one is applied to optimization, the
other is applied to optimization on
probability distributions of Aka
sampling.
Great.
Daniel: I guess last question on this
part.
What is the shadow Hamiltonian and why
does it sound so cool?
Lance: I know, right?
Yeah, it's really cool.
It's a recall name.
So the shadow of Hamiltonian is okay, so
let's go back to the Hamiltonian.
So we have a Hamiltonian, and we want to
simulate the dynamic that preserve the
Hamiltonian.
We want to implement that on the
computer.
We're going to do that through geometric
integration.
Geometric integration gives you a bunch
of algorithms to preserve the
Hamiltonian.
I mean, a bunch of algorithms they can
implement on the computer, and they're
going to preserve the Hamiltonian.
Do they actually really preserve the
Hamiltonian?
It turns out that no.
So what I said before is a bit of a
shortcut, because the numerical
integration that you get through any
numerical method, including geometric
integration, is not going to exactly
preserve the Hamiltonian, but it's going
to preserve what people call a shadow
hamiltonian, which is almost the same as
the Hamiltonian, but with extra terms
that sort of vanish if the time step is
very short.
So this is to say that your numerical
dynamic implemented through geometric
integration is going to exactly preserve
the shadow Hamiltonian and approximately
preserve the true Hamiltonian.
In the papers, we show I don't know if
it's well, it's probably algorithm
dependent, but basically, depending on
the algorithm that you choose, you want
to show to what extent the shadow
Hamiltonian truly approximates the true
Hamiltonian.
The virtue of geometric integration
methods is that actually the shadow
Hamiltonian turns out to be extremely
close to true Hamiltonian, which dean
that you can take a very long time steps
and still be very good at preserving the
true Hamiltonian.
So here, when you implement these
methods, you don't exactly preserve the
true Hamiltonian, but you still do it
pretty well.
And so in Hamiltonian Monte Carlo, the
momentum refreshment, and Metropolis,
usually the Metropolis Hastings accept
rejects that is going to correct for
those failures of truly preserving the
Hamiltonian.
So even though you don't exactly preserve
the Hamiltonian in your numerical
integration, in Hamiltonian Monte Carlo,
the Metropolis hating accept reject step
is going to correct for this inaccuracy.
And so this is like, really the true
beauty of Hamiltonian Monte Carlo is that
even though you get a lot of things that
are not exactly preserved when you
implement things on a computer.
Thanks to Metropolitan Hastings, overall
your sampling is going to be perfect in
the sense that you're going to truly
preserve your target distribution.
So this is really the key.
Now, a follow up question to that is,
okay, well, if Metropolis Hastings is
just so crucial and it just gives your
dynamic the property that it's going to
preserve, whatever it does, even if it
samples really badly if?
You add Metropolis Hastings, it's still
going to preserve your Target
distribution.
Then why can't You Just Come up with an
average process, like whatever Kind Of
process?
And that Metropolis Hastings at the end?
And so you can do that.
You can take any kind of process.
Let's say you take a random process, it
could be the worst in the world.
Let's say you wanted to sample from a
gaussian and you actually take a Brown in
motion.
Now this is clearly not going to work
because Brown Emotion just goes all over
the place.
It could go infinitely far.
Brown in motion, it's just like random
action, right?
Completely random motion.
There is structure to it, but the
structure in Brown in Motion means that
it's such that brown in motion is just
going to just spread really far.
So Brown in motion is not going to
preserve your target distribution and
it's also going to be very slow, by the
way.
So it's not going to be a good sampler if
you add Metropolis Hastings on Brown
emotion, which is you integrate brand
action.
So you simulate a step of brand emotion
on the computer and then you do
Metropolis Hastings to know whether you
should accept or reject that step.
Metropolis Hastings will tell you whether
you should do it or not.
You either accept and you keep going from
that new position, or you reject and you
start from where you started from and
take a new sample.
Accept, reject.
If you accept, you keep going.
If you reject, you go back and you sort
of go like that.
So if you do materially facing there,
your standard is going to be exact.
So it is going to preserve the target and
so you're going to have accurate sound
plan.
And so this is crucial.
This really highlights the importance of
Metropolis Hastings.
But there is a big but your sampler here
is going to be extremely slow.
It's going to be extremely slow, first of
all, because brand in action in and of
itself, it doesn't at all preserve the
target distribution.
I mean, it just goes all over the place.
And you just want to sample a lot around
the mode of the gaussian, for example.
So it means that Metropolis hasting will
reject a lot of your steps because a lot
of your steps will try to go further away
while you want to stay around the mode
typically of the gapsin.
So you're going to do a lot of steps for
nothing and also Brown in Motion just
does not have the qualities that make a
sampler efficient.
And so the reason why Hamiltonian Monte
Carlo is so good is because it's able to
integrate Metropolis Hastings and still
preserve a lot of other properties that
make the sampler efficient.
So if we remember, HamiltonI Monte Carlo
has this geometric integration that does
not exactly preserve the Hamiltonian, but
it does still does it pretty well
approximately by preserving a shadow
Hamiltonian.
So this means already that integration
step is going to be really good.
So there's going to be a lot of
acceptance in the Metropolis Hastings and
also the way the scheme is set up,
there's going to be a lot of acceptance
set in the Metropolis Hastings.
So it means that most of the samples that
you would draw will actually be used
instead of being rejected and you have to
start over again.
That's one advantage.
The other advantage of Hamiltonium and T
Carlo, and this is a crucial one and we
kind of discussed this last week, is that
one crucial thing to be a good sampler is
this idea of time irreversibility.
So I'll emphasize it again because it's
really crucial and there's a lot of
literature on this and it's something
that we reviewed also in the paper.
So a sampler that is time reversible that
is time irreversible is always going to
be better or it's at least not going to
be worse than a sampler that is time
reversible.
So what do we mean by this?
A sample is time irreversible?
If and on the if were you to play the
dynamics forward or backward, there will
be going on your bullet point here.
A sample is time reversible if and on the
if you were to play the dynamics forward
or backward in time, so forward in time
and then maybe you would play them by
reversing the movie by playing the movie
backwards.
If you were to do that, then the two
movies that you would see would be
qualitatively the same and statistically
the same.
So the process is time reversible if and
only if the process, if you're running
forward or backward, it's basically
statistically the same.
Now, what does this mean in practice?
Well, if your process is time reversible,
then it's going to backtrack very often,
actually.
So it means that you would be somewhere
in the probability distribution, just
something there and you will go forward
and then you probably go backward and so
on and you kind of get stuck in a region
until you go somewhere else.
But it's just going to be very slow to
move around and so it's going to be very
slow to get good sampling because it's
going to take you a long time to visit
all the regions of the probate
distribution.
In other words, the distribution
characterizing the process.
It's going to move very slowly to the
target distribution that's another way to
look at it.
If the process is time irreversible, on
the other hand, then it's a lot less
likely to go backward during the sampling
process.
So it means that it's going to visit the
target distribution a lot more.
I mean, it's just going to go around.
Imagine if you're not allowed to go
backward just as a human being and you're
walking around, you're just going to end
up in many more places than if you were
allowed to go backward.
And if you were just going backward all
the time to where you started, then you
wouldn't be able to do a lot of
visiting.
So it would be a bad sampler.
So again, there's some, like
straightforward intuition there.
So one idea is in sampling is we want to
optimize the extent to which a sampler is
timely reversible.
We want to increase time irreversibility
as much as we can force a sampler to just
move around as much as possible.
So that's an idea.
It is explored currently.
I guess it's a bit of an open problem of
how do you really do that and how do you
implement that on the computer in a way
that works and preserves all the
properties.
But the point I wanted to get to is that
Metropolis Hastings is a blessing and
it's also a curse.
It is a blessing because when you add it
to any kind of process, you will make
your sampling unbiased.
So it means that you will sample the Ride
distribution even though you're
implementing this on a computer.
And there can be a lot, so many issues
with the numerical integration, numerical
approximation and so on.
But it's also a curse because whenever
you add Metropolis Hastings on the
process, it's going to make it time
reversible.
Actually, yeah, if you just took a random
process and added metropolisA, you would
get something that's inevitably going to
be quite slow.
And so now you get to the problem or the
conundrum.
What do I do?
Do I go for unbiased sampling?
Do I care about accuracy?
And then I should add Metropolis
Hastings.
Or do I not care about accuracy so much
and then I should not have Metropolis
Hastings and it's going to go faster
generally.
And so Hamiltonia Monte Carlo actually
has the blessing and does not have the
curse.
And this is why Hamiltonian Monte Carlo
is just so good.
And again, it's also complementary to all
of the things that we've been
discussing.
And the reason why Hamiltonian Monte
Carlo is blessed and not cursed is
because the momentum, how do you call
this?
The Metropolis Hastings is just done on
the momentum refreshment step as opposed
to being done on the overall dynamic.
So because if you remember, you do
geometric integration to simulate
Hamiltonian dynamics, every once in a
while you will take a momentum
refreshment and then do Metropolis
Hastings on that momentum refreshment, as
opposed to doing Metropolis Hastings on
both the Hamiltonian dynamic and the
momentum refreshment.
So it's not something that I can really
explain how that works, but it turns out
that by just doing the Metropolis method,
montacarlo is a way of having Metropolis
Hastings in a way that you preserve the
unbiasedness so that your sampling is
accurate, but you don't sacrifice the
time irreversibility.
And so you get both.
And this is because the Metropolis
hasting is just on one of the components
and not on both.
Daniel: To kind of connect that to an
example.
As we move into active inference here, we
have some probability isocontours, some,
we have the high probability carpool
lane, and then we have some lower
probability lanes, and we can go
different speeds in these lanes.
And we want to have a full accelerated
model here.
It's almost like the MH is refreshing our
velocity just asking when we want to
change the lanes.
But it's not our full self driving car
Metropolis Hastings algorithm.
But we're able to use our position and
acceleration when we're in our lane to
take full advantage of the acceleration
following the shadow road.
Not necessarily the true road, but the
shadow road is close enough, or the
shadows on the road, and then lane
changes.
Are these computationally costly and
reversible, but still super useful
propositions?
Lance: Exactly.
And they're actually not computationally
costly.
They would be if you were to reject many
samples.
But here in Hamiltonian Monte Carto,
typically you don't get to reject many
samples.
So yeah, that's such a great picture.
So the car follows the Shadow Road by
just doing geometric integration and
following the shadow.
Hamiltonian every once in a while, you
get a momentum refreshment.
Velocity refreshment, which is, oh, now I
move to the first lane, or the second
lane, third lane, and so on.
And you get a Metropolis Hastings
Corrections step that says, do I accept
this proposal of lane change or do I
reject it?
And still on the coast.
Daniel: So how does this connect active
inference lab?
Lance: Well, I mean, great question.
So active imprints in active inference
proper, you don't have any sampling in
active imprints.
Whenever you want to scale active
inference to implement it, to solve any
kind of problem in the world, you want to
do sampling because there's a lot of
computations that are not going to be
trackable otherwise.
And so one cool example is in the figure
after this, actually.
So for any kind of decision making active
inference lab, you need to approximate
the expected free energy.
The one just before yeah, perfect.
So if you look at the second equation
there, you get this minus lock p of an
action sequence equals expectation of
something.
This minus lock p of the action sequence
is our notation in this paper for the
expected free energy.
You probably all know this, the expected
free energy is given by the expectation
of something.
Now typically, and when you have a very
high dimensional model, which happens in
most applications, I would say you get a
very high dimensional expectation.
What is an expectation?
An expectation is an integral with
respect to probability distribution.
How do you compute expectations while you
do that?
Through sampling, or at least sampling is
the way to compute high dimensional
expectations.
That's the most efficient in statistics.
And this is the reason why sampling is
studied in statistics, is because that's
how you solve these problems.
I mean, expectations just come up
everywhere, just like so many things
about machine learning bowl down to
computing expectations.
And so here in particular, the
expectation that is very dear to us, very
close to our hearts, is the one that
gives you the expected free energy.
The expected is the expectation of
something.
So how do you compute that in a high
dimensional model where you have to use
something?
There comes the usefulness of Hamiltonian
Monte Carlo.
If you have a discrete state space based
model, you're not going to be able to use
Hamiltonian Monte Carlo because
Hamiltonian Monte Carlo is on continuous
states based models.
It's on continuous state space, right?
We talked about continuous positions,
continuous velocity.
I talked about something a probability
distribution on my desk, which is a
continuous state space.
So you're not going to be able to use
Hamiltonian Monte Carlo if you have
partially observed mark of decision
process and you're doing active inference
there.
But if you have for example, I've been
talking recently to Ryan Smith, who does
a lot of active inference, and he's
really leading a lot of the modeling work
with active inference and real data of
patients of all sorts, many medical data,
and also using active inference to model
psychological experiments.
And one of the things he told me about
well is, okay, well, I have a bunch of
data, and partially observed markup
decision process is just not going to do
it.
Why is he not going to do it?
Because the data that he has lives on a
continuous space.
I don't remember exactly what it was, but
let's just say, for the sake of example,
that that data was the temperature in the
room, and the subjects had to infer the
temperature in the room based on their
sensations.
So that's a continuous state space
problem.
Now, imagine that you ask someone to
infer the temperature in the room.
Then maybe you would change the
temperature in the room or not, and you
would ask them again.
Change the temperature or not and ask
them again, and so on.
When you have this sort of set up, you
have a discrete you have a phenomenon
that unfolds in discrete time because you
just repeatedly ask some questions and
sometimes elapses between the questions.
But you also have a state space that's
continuous.
When you have this sort of data, then the
kind of model that you want to use is a
partially observed mark of decision
process that we know and love but the
state space is going to be continuous
instead of discrete.
The planet is still going to be
discreet.
Now, when you have this sort of model, I
just want to say it or as an aside, that
for the moment, a lot of the modeling
work and simulation work in Active
inference uses the sweet state space
pound DPS, partially observed mark of the
same process just because it's been
sufficient.
And when you simulate agent is often like
in grid worlds and when you maybe have a
state spaces in experiments they often by
design discrete because it's just easier
to handle.
But that's not something, that's not an
assumption, a simplifying assumption that
we're going to be able to keep for that
much longer.
There's just so many things that you
cannot account with these sort of
models.
So one other model that is interesting to
have is partially observed Markov
decision process, but with a continuous
state space.
So with those you get the problem of
estimating the expected free energy which
would be then an expectation or in other
words, an integration, an integral in a
continuous takes place.
And so how do you do that efficiently if
you are in a high dimensional state
space?
Where do you use?
Hamilton, monte Carlo.
I think this wouldn't be really the
best.
So this is how you join the dots in this
paper.
We didn't talk about sampling in discrete
space because the methods are quite
different.
So we really had to choose what to focus
on.
There's of course a lot more methods in
the literature than there are in this
paper.
We just wanted to sort of review what
were the main ones and what people really
used in practice.
But when you have the expected principal
in a discrete state space, computing the
expectation that defines the expected
priority can often be a little bit easier
because it comes down computationally to
a bunch of matrix multiplications.
Matrix vector multiplications, which
generally is doable, unless the state
space is enormously high.
And then we'd have to think of sampling
methods in this sweet space.
But as soon as you move to a partially
observed markup decision process with a
continuous space, which are argu and Ryan
Smith argues and I'm sure a lot of people
have run into this as soon as you have
this kind of model, well, yeah, you just
have an integration problem in continuous
space.
And so Hamiltonium Altekaro is the way to
go there.
Daniel: Awesome.
And your 2020 paper was a synthesis on
some of the discrete statespace
formalisms of active.
So it's very interesting to see how
you're now talking about where continuous
time, continuous state spaces can come
into play and how interesting the Active
inference has the capacity to deal with
discrete and continuous date spaces.
And sometimes we lean on one leg or the
other leg more, but it spans the gap in a
way that's actually like a value adding,
not like there's some sort of missing
piece from one side or the other.
Lance: Yeah, definitely.
I think active inference is great because
it's so flexible in the sort of models
that you can consider.
But yeah, historically the first models
to be developed were continuous space and
continuous time.
And then it works quite well because you
can take gradients of the free energy and
just minimize them over time.
So you could get around basically
everything by doing a grain and assemble
free energy.
And then after that around like so that
was like 2010.
And then around 2015, people started
thinking, okay, well, how do I model
discrete time decision making with active
inference and typically decision making
tasks, at least the simple ones that are
studied in neuroscience and behavior
neuroscience, just to make things simple,
the number of actions that you have is
discrete.
So you have a finite number of actions,
which is pretty small.
You would also have a finite number of
states, which would be pretty small.
And then people started to think, okay,
well, how do we active inference lab to
actually account for that?
And so, yes, and so that's how the whole
expectation free energy and partially
observed mark of decision processes came
into play.
And now the community has grown a lot and
there's more and more data that we want
to account for.
There's more and more projects that are
going on and, you know, people are
realizing it's an obvious realization.
It's not surprising at all that these two
models developed in 2010, 2015.
They they're just not going to account
for everything.
You need to think about other kinds of
models.
It really depends on what kind of data
you have at hand.
And then one important and obvious type
of model would be partially observed
Markov decision process with continuous
space.
And actually, this is not a new thing.
I mean, people have been using these kind
of models in reinforcement learning and
control for a long time.
I don't know to what extent they've
arrived at practically I mean, they
arrived at practically instrumental
algorithms.
I don't know to what extent they're used,
to what extent their state of the art.
But the point is, it's something that
it's a kind of model that has existed for
a long time.
And so this sampling would be a way to
actually practically implement this and
scale it when you want to put that within
active inference.
So I think it's an important thing to
think about.
Daniel: Awesome.
Lance: Yeah.
Daniel: Thomas Parr, also recently in a
discussion on the textbook was sharing
some timelines.
And it's just so interesting how these
things have been developing and from
continuous through characterization of
the discrete, in a sense not culminating,
but being synthesized in your 2020
paper.
And now there's with an increased
emphasis on empirical data, the desire to
bring in a lot of these methods that
actually help us implement it rather than
just think about it, really
parsimoniously.
So what is your active inference
representation in the figure of the
running person?
And then how do the variables and the
processes described in this figure relate
to all of this?
5 hours of talking about Shadow
Hamiltonians.
Lance: And all of this, right?
Yeah, that's a broad question.
We might need another Daniel to answer
that in detail, but just very short.
Well, the active inference section was
meant to be as complete as possible, even
though it was very short.
And by completeness I mean that we
started by deriving active inference and
deriving active inference free energy
principle.
So this is really what the free energy
principle does, even though we weren't
able of course, to review the whole free
energy principle in like one or two
pages.
But what we focused on was deriving the
expected free energy free energy
principle and then from there you get the
full active inference algorithm.
So full active inference algorithm, I
think you just went past it's just below
if you go slightly below, I think maybe
page 29 or page 30 still, I think next
realizing an active agents.
So this is the active infrastructure
algorithm, like 0.12.3 or something, just
from a duration of the expected pre
energy.
You actually get as a corollary from
there, the active imprint algorithm that
we know and love.
This is actually a more general version
than what people use and I'm be excited
and I'm actually talking to people to
actually implement that.
But this is actually the most general
version that has been established in the
literature and it is more general in a
meaningful way in the sense that all the
beliefs, all the probability
distribution, they are over trajectories
or sequences of events.
So it means that all the computations,
they not only consider events at a
particular time in the future, for
example, but they consider trajectories
of sequences of events.
And so this is considering different
events at different points in time and
their independencies and dependencies
between them.
So this is just to say that if you would
take then this algorithm and you would
perform a mini field approximation over
time, which is saying that all the things
that you see in the future are sort of
independent of each other at different
points in time, then you would recover
what people typically use in the
literature, which is easily
implementable.
The point I want to make here is that you
can actually not have that limitation and
have things that are a bit more complex,
that are able to capture more complex
relationships in the time series and
input that.
They may be receiving, like, the kind of
sensory data that they may be receiving
and the kind of generative models that
they would have.
So anyway, this is the active inference
algorithm, the most general one.
We derive that from first principles by
deriving the expected community from
first principles.
And so this relates us to that figure
that you just showed.
So that figure that you showed with S on
A is the starting point of the free
energy principle described in this
paper.
And so the point is that we want to
describe decision making, want to
describe actions as a function of
sensations, and we want to come up with
the most general description of actions
as a function of sensations to be able to
account for everything.
That's kind of the idea of the pre
engineer principle.
So what do we do is we consider a world,
a world in which there is an environment
and an agent.
And so the environment here is denoted by
S, and S is a stochastic process.
Why a stochastic process?
Because a stochastic process is the most
general type of dynamic that exists, at
least as far as I know.
It's really a random dynamic.
And it could be random in all sorts of
ways.
It could also be non random.
We sort of take the stochastic, the
random aspect, as an extra ingredient,
just to include a lot more types of
scenarios and things you can be
confronted with.
So you partition the world into the
agent, which is O and A, and the
environment, which is S, and the agent.
Then you subdivide it into two more
components, which are O and A.
O are what we call the observable
states.
These are like the sensations of the
observations that you get at any point in
time, also a stochastic process.
And finally, you have the autonomous
states.
Or you could think about it loosely as
the active states.
They turn out to be the active states in
the implementation.
But so the active states, they're really
like the muscles, the things you can
actually activate and make and then
activate to influence the world.
So we just partitioned the world into
these three sets of states that interact
and evolve in some way.
They're both stochastic processes that
interact.
And the goal of the community principle,
at least when applied to decision making,
is that you want to describe A as a
function of O, because what happens as an
organism, you have control over A, you
have access.
To O, but you don't have direct control
of O over your sensations.
And you don't have access to S because
that's the environment and beyond the
markup.
Like it beyond you, beyond your
envelope.
So you don't have access to S.
You know, O and you can control A is what
you can choose from.
And so the free energy principle just
answers the question, okay, well, if I
take this very general description of the
world, what is the equation of A as a
function of O?
How can I describe A as a function of o?
And so it turns out there's some mild
assumptions in this.
And these assumptions, they're guided by
physical considerations about how humans
are and how humans interact with the
world, but they're very mild.
But whenever you take.
These assumptions, you get that the
active states or the autonomous states
minimize expected free energy.
So this is like a very 16th derivation of
the expected free energy.
From first principles, we start with the
partition of the world.
We describe active states as a function
of observations.
As it turns out, that the expected free
energy is what describes the active
states as a function of observations.
The basic active inference algorithm,
which everybody uses and which we have
also in paper, is about computing the
expected free energy and then selecting
actions that minimizes expected free
energy.
So the expected free energy, as we saw, I
think it's in the next figure.
So the one with all the panels, we've
seen it a couple of times already.
It's an expectation with posterior
distributions in it.
What I mean by posterior distributions
here is that these are distributions
conditioned on the history of the agent,
so on the observations that he has
already seen and on the action that he
has already taken.
In any case, the expected free energy is
an expectation with posterior
distributions within.
So it means that to compute the expected
free energy, you have two problems.
You have computing posterior distribution
through Bayes and inference, Bayesian
rule.
And once you have them, you can plug them
in into this equation.
And then you need to complete the the
expectation, and then you get the
expected free energy.
So the first thing is about computing the
posterior distributions.
Now, what has been proposed in the
literature so far is, well, how do you do
approximate inference?
How do you actually approximate
distributions?
You do that through variational inference
or approximate inference by minimizing
free energy.
The treatment here, the derivation, and
our aim was to do that, provide a
derivation that was as conceptually
simple as possible.
Actually, it highlights that the free
energy is not the most important thing
here.
The important thing is really the
expected free energy.
The free energy is just a tool to
approximate the posterior distributions,
to then get the expected free energy.
But you could actually use any other type
of divergence.
The free energy is just like a KL
divergence plus some term that makes the
whole thing tractable.
And so you can minimize the KL divergence
to approximate the target distribution.
But actually, what this view highlights,
and by the way, I'm not at all against
the free energy.
I think it's really cool.
And there's so many methods to minimize
free energy.
If you can do that, then fine and sure,
go for it.
Like, way to go.
But imagine you could not do that.
It would not at all be a problem because
you could use any other kind of
divergence to solve those inference
problems.
So that would be the first step.
You can approximate those particular
distributions by doing some kind of
approximate inference, which would be
through minimization of reenergy or
through minimization of something else.
And then you have the second step, which
is computing the expectation.
Now, either you're in a low number of
states, discrete states from the P like
thing and it's all a matter of vector
matrix multiplications that are
attractable.
Either you have a very high number of
discrete states and then you need to
think about sampling in discrete states,
which we didn't discuss in this paper.
Either you are in a continuous state
space and then you have an expectation in
continuous state space and then you want
to think about an alternative Monte
Carlo, for example.
So now with these two steps you have now
an estimate of the expected free energy
which gives you the quality of any action
sequence.
And so it's not only the quality, but
it's actually the negative Lock
probability of any action sequence
regarding in this formalism.
Because if you remember, the premise of
all this was to describe actions as
functional sensations in a physical
system, not even a physical system, but
in interacting stochastic processes.
And so the answer to that was well, the
expected free energy gives us how actions
relate to sensations, the expected free
energy.
And this is why we used the letter, we
used minus Lock p as opposed to G to
emphasize that the expected free energy
is not just like a function of action
sequences, but it is really the negative
log probability of an action sequence
given some sensations.
And so once you have computed the
expected free energy, you had this minus
log probability of an action sequence.
If you take the exponential negative of
that, the exponential negative of the
expected free energy, you get the
probability distribution over action
sequences.
And so by the way, this exponential
negative of expected free energy is what
we use all the time.
You might recognize this as the soft max
of negative expected free energy.
This is just all the time kind of
fundamental thing, active inference lab
models.
So I'm really talking about the same
thing here.
So once you take the soft max of negative
expected free energy, you get P of A,
which is the distribution over action
sequences.
And now you have two possibilities.
Either you want to stimulate the most
likely action sequence, in which case you
want to simulate the action sequence that
maximizes the probability distribution.
So in effect, you have an optimization
problem out of all.
Yeah, you need to find the action
sequence that is going to maximize this
probability distribution that's given by
the expected free energy or you want to
simulate a typical action.
So when do I mean a typical action?
A typical action or a typical action
sequence is just a sample from the
distribution.
And so if you want to sample from I mean,
if you want to do that, then you have a
sampling problem where again you need to
sample from a distribution over action
sequences given by the expected free
energy.
So this is really how all these
methodologies connect.
I think that's kind of it, yeah.
One last thing is, typically when we
stimulate active inference, we never do
the sampling at the end.
We always take the action sequence that
minimizes expected free energy.
In other words, the action sequence that
maximizes that probability distribution.
And this is because when we simulate
things, it turns out this is how people
have done it in the literature.
People are more interested in the most
likely action sequence that an organism
or an agent would produce.
But if you want to model data, if you
want to use active inference to model
data, then you actually want to not just
simulate the most likely action sequence,
but simulate any kind of action sequence
that would fall out of this.
And so this is really the case where you
need to sample from that final
distribution as opposed to do your
optimization.
So depending on the use case, you either
have a sampling or an optimization
problem after you've computed the
expected free energy.
So this is how these whole things fall
together.
And so you might be asking, okay, well,
you talked about sampling and
optimization.
There's also a section about inference.
Where does that fit in?
And so it fits in on the remark I gave
that we have these postered distributions
within the expected free energy.
How do we compute them?
How do we approximate them?
One way is by minimizing free energy.
Another way is by minimizing any other
kind of divergence.
And in that section over there, we just
reviewed some kind of divergences that
are very popular in the statistical
inference literature, mainly because they
have desirable properties.
And so if you weren't able to use the
variation of free energy for some reason,
or maybe something to be explored, and
something to be explored is just to use
other types of divergences and just see
what happens.
So the open problem to be explored is
whether we can get better performance by
using different kinds of divergences and
see what we get.
Maybe there's part of algorithms that are
out there with these other types of
divergences that we can make use of to do
better performance, to get better
performance.
Can we actually describe and quantify the
improvements in performance that we get
by using these other types of
algorithms?
When would these be appropriate and
useful?
These are all open questions.
Another open question that I think is
interesting is can we model maladaptive
behavior by using different kinds of
divergences that would not work as well
as the free energy?
And there's an interesting paper on that
by newer sajid and colleagues.
I think it's called Bayesian Brains and
the Rennie Divergence.
It's been published on neurocomputation,
I think, last year or the year before.
And so in that paper, instead of using
the variation of free energy to
approximate all these posterior
distributions, she used the rainy
divergence, which is which generalizes
the KL divergence in some way, and show
that for different rainy divergences, you
get different types of approximate
posteriors.
And she basically looked into what kind
of differences you get from there in
terms of perception, in terms of
decisionmaking.
And she showed that for that particular
divergence, divergence, I think the
conclusion was that you basically get
different phenomenology, you get
different behavior, suggest something to
be explored.
I think the upshot was that maybe I don't
remember how far the paper went in this,
but I think kind of the goal was to model
maladaptive behavior using some kinds of
rainy divergences that did not work as
well as the free energy.
So this is to say, so this is an
interesting work.
One could examine other kinds of
divergences and see whether you actually
get better or worse performance than with
the free energy.
One thing, one word of caution, though,
is the free energy is just so good in the
sense that it uses the KL divergence.
And as I mentioned at the beginning, the
KL divergence has so many properties and
it's just so fundamental.
It's not straightforward to see that when
you first come up with it.
But I guess the more I read in different
disciplines and the more the Chao
divergence comes up and the more the more
I see properties of Kale divergence in
different disciplines that just make it
so interesting.
Like, for example, the Kale divergence,
Bayesian Statistics Physics is the
relative entropy.
So it quantifies the amount of entropy
that a distribution has with respect to
another.
Entropy, as we know, is just a very
fundamental thing in information theory.
The KL divergence quantifies the
difference in information between two
distributions, the amount of bits that
you would need to if you take two
distributions, A and B, the KL between
the two quantifies the amount of
information that it takes to go from one
to the other.
So now you might object and say, okay,
but KL A and B is different from KL, B
and A.
And so how can it be that it quantifies
the amount of information they need to go
from A to B or B to A because it's not
symmetric.
So the answer is it's either KL of A and
B that has this meaning, or KL of B and A
that has this meaning.
And I just can never remember which
direction, but it's one of them that has
this interpretation in terms of the
difference in information anyway.
So Kia is just like something, it just
comes up everywhere and it's just so
useful, and it has all of these nice
properties which makes these free energy
really a construct of choice.
But that said, there's other divergences,
one of them which we describe a bit in
the paper called the maximum mean
discrepancy, which I think also has
properties.
It's not necessarily well, it's very
different in terms of how you construct
it from the KL divergence.
But I think my current understanding
right now.
And my current understanding right now is
that if you cannot use KL, then maximum
mean discrepancy is just like, be nice.
But yeah.
So the word of caution was that probably
most divergences out there are not going
to do as good of a job as a free energy,
but some clever ones might.
And it's an open problem of determining
which is how we get the link between all
these different sections.
So to do perception, we need the
inference.
To do decision making, that is, computing
the expected free energy, we need
sampling typically.
And then to do action selection, we
either need sampling or optimization.
And also inference is an optimization of
belief.
Updating also, as we've discussed, is
also an optimization of probability
distributions.
You can see that as an optimization of
beliefs as well.
So it's all very tightly interconnected.
Wow.
Daniel: Thank you, Lance.
That's very informative.
Brings up a lot of ways to go and it
really shines a different light on even
what, learning active inference or
learning free energy principle.
It was a roller coaster just listening.
When you describe the figure of the
running person and the new generalized
representation here, which is so sparse
it looks like it's pseudocode, but it's
actually basically necessary and
sufficient to describe action.
Lance: Yeah, it is pseudocode and it is
also exact like this is really what
active inference boils down to.
And that was kind of like where we got
at.
We're like, okay, well, we had this mess
of papers of active inference.
Not that they're actually immense, but,
you know, there's so much information and
we're really thinking, reading all the
latest free energy principle literature
that I've also worked on a lot and also
active inference lab literature and
really thinking, okay, well, how do we
strip all that of the neuroscience?
How do we strip all that of the cognitive
science?
How do we just retain the math and
present it in the simplest way possible?
That would be appealing for mathematician
and also hopefully for a computer
scientist.
It turns out that we got a way simpler
perspective than anything that's out
there, I think.
And really?
Yeah.
So this is the active inference algorithm
in pseudocode and in detail also in a
way.
Daniel: So totally agree.
Again, thanks for the work and for
sharing it this way because it is the
fewest pixels for the highest resolution
picture.
Then to describe the fundamental
cybernetic challenge as a partition, an
axiomatic partition, which one can then
say also has grounding in the spatial
temporal boundaries of the world or in
geometric boundaries in informational
spaces.
But the particular partition is used to
separate in the map, not necessarily
making claims about the territory and the
actual nature of the objects and their
articulations or anatomy, but on the map,
which we get to construct.
We make it in a way that's amenable to
the particular partition, which is not
too much more than the separation of
figure from ground or agent based
modeling.
It's just a separation of some autonomous
entity from some external process.
Then the task of the free energy
principle applied to decision making, as
you said, was to describe action as a
function of observation and everything in
between is broadly considered cognitive
but for any given system it's going to
play out in this immensely nuanced way
with a lot of bespoke mechanisms.
And why do we take that particular
partition step?
Well, it's kind of like read, write
access in the computer system there's
things we don't have access to hidden
states and also the reverse of that which
is we can't access hidden states nor them
influence or affect us.
So I think of that as like no
telekinesis, no telepathy.
You can't go directly across the
blanket.
You have to intermediate through the
blanket of observation and action.
And then with respect to our particular
states, our blanket and internal states,
we have access to observations, but not
direct control, nor necessarily would we
want to.
Because if we had the lever to change
what we directly received, then
algorithms might learn strategies that
basically self deceive so that the
observations look good, look good, look
good, until the whole system crashes.
So we want access to observations but not
direct control.
And then the autonomous states are what
we in the optimal ideal situation have
total control of which is like our mind
and our body, what we think and what we
do.
It turns out through the pragmatic turn
and the inactivist insights in cognitive
science that a lot of action sequences
have to do with changing what
observations are sought after like
epistemic affordance.
So there is an enmeshment of action but
it's also really important that we have
access but not control of observations.
We don't want to have our control on the
thermometer but we want the best possible
thermometer and then we want to control
the best possible interpretation that's
like signal processing and the best
possible action sequence which is like
decision making and control theory.
And then free energy principle is
addressing that question what is the
equation of action as a function of
observation?
But then it was quite a rollercoaster
when you said that the free energy wasn't
even necessarily the only way to do it.
But it's absolutely true.
The properties of the free energy are
inherited from one of the terms being KL
divergence and the other having the
ability to basically ignore in certain
relative expected free energy calculation
contexts.
So then in that situation differences in
free energy do come down to differences
in the KL which does have all these
properties.
But that doesn't mean that the free
energy is itself axiomatically posited
it's actually downstream of the
particular partition to use free energy
or anything like that at all and other
discrepancies may have other properties
in different ways.
Lance: Exactly.
There's a bit of a nuance in the sense
that here we presented version of the
free energy principle, just describing
decision making as you summarize though
describing A as a function of O.
And by the way, about that, we didn't
even talk about Markov blanket in this
paper.
I would say that the markup blanket is
under the hood because we're saying,
okay, well, these are the states that you
have access to and these are the states
that you do not.
The states that you have access to are A
and O.
The states are the agent.
The states that you do not have access to
are the environment.
So in some sense there is a markup
blanket, but we didn't even have to
mention that in the paper.
It's just you partition the world into
three sets of states, S, O and A, that
are by definition A.
And you just yeah, just from this trip
partition, you want to describe one as a
function of another, ignoring the third.
And so that's how you derive expected
green energy.
You see that action sequences are
described by the expected free energy.
And this is a functional sensations if we
want further in the and so this is just
what you need crucially, this is just
what you need to derive.
Active Inference Lab Algorithm if we went
further in reviewing the free energy
principle, then we would see the
fundamental role that the free energy
plays.
And so actually, when reading the latest
papers on the mathematical theory of the
free energy principle, the role of the
variation of free energy is pretty
clear.
But here the point is that if we just
care about decision making, if we just
care about the normal active inference
algorithm, then we don't even need the
variation of free energy.
So sure, the free energy should be
preferred.
Why not, if it is available?
But if it is not for some reason, then
there's no reason why not to use another
kind of divergence.
Daniel: Very interesting.
It's making me think about linear
regression and the sum of squares, the L
two norm is one approach that's often
used to fit a regression line because it
has good optimization properties, there's
good software packages, there's good
education, there's good communication
around it and so on.
But one can select other norms and choose
to fit a linear regression with an L one
norm or with an L three norm.
And so that entire question of fitting
the linear aggression is a degree of
freedom.
How the regression is fit, that's
downstream of a commitment to, for
example, model a system in a generalized
linear modeling framework.
And so analogously, the upstream
commitment or the first principles which
yes, can be understood as axiomatic and
also have some empirical status in terms
of this partitioning.
A figure from ground the particular
partition can simply be accepted
axiomatically, which is to say without
appeal to evidence.
Or somebody might have another upstream
axiom and choose to model things
according to a particular partition.
From there, just like we could have
chosen the L one, two, three norm there
are different discrepancy criteria or
measures that we might want to use, and
some of them apply better or worse or not
at all, depending on what software,
hardware, data set, and generative model
we have.
And so it makes sense.
Pull back into the upstream understanding
active inference lab as a process theory
for particular partitioned systems.
And then for those who want to engage in
the modeling to have that discussion
about the garden of the branching paths,
well, you could use a discrete time or
you could use a continuous time, and then
from here, you could do this sampling.
Or you could do that one.
And if we have this computer access, we
can do that.
But if we have to do it this way, we'll
do it like that.
And that's all operational and
logistical, but it's actually all under
the umbrella or under the auspice of the
theoretical or conceptual commitments
that are actually not being questioned
once one is in that modeling discussion.
Just like you could have the L one two
three norm conversation, and maybe a
reviewer asks you why you chose the two
norm versus the three.
But it's a broader level of questioning
why one took on the linear modeling
framework at all.
And our analogous upstream bottleneck,
not in terms of rate limiting, but just
in terms of like, eye of the needle is
the particular partition.
Lance: Yes, definitely.
And I just want to add something actually
about the choice of divergences or the
choice of discrepancy that you might want
to use to solve the inference problem.
I think the analogy with linear
regression is a really good one.
When you do linear regression, yeah, you
can use all types of norms, and it's
really a design choice here in the
algorithm, you also have that design
choice that you're going to use KL.
So free energy to do active inference.
By the way, the inferences are really
equation 43 and 44, which are approximate
actually, you had them in the slide.
Daniel: Already, 43 and 44 here, got it.
Lance: Which are approximate some
posterior distribution with an
approximate posterior distribution.
So you can do that with the pre energy,
which is the same as the KL divergence,
or you could do that with a whole bunch
of other divergences.
One that I mentioned and that I think is
particularly interesting is the maximum
mean discrepancy.
And so here's the difference between KL
and maximum dean discrepancy, at least, I
guess, an important conceptual
difference.
So the KL, when you look at distributions
that are very close to each other, it's
basically going to become symmetric when
the distributions are very close, and
it's going to measure the amount of
information that differs between them.
The maximum mean discrepancy, when you
take two distributions that are very
close, it reduces to what people call the
Earth movers distance, also called like
the vanishing distance so here's an
intuition.
If you take two distributions that are
very close, just imagine distribution A
as a pack of dirt and distribution B as a
pack of dirt or a sand with some shape.
The maximum mean discrepancy is going to
tell you the amount of work that you need
to put all that dirt from distribution A
and pile it in the shape of distribution
B.
So of course, there's so many different
ways in which you could take all that
dirt from distribution A and remodel it
in distribution B, but you're interested
in the minimal energetic cost that would
take.
So like the optimal way of doing that
movement, people call that optimal
transport.
Now, if you're familiar with optimal
transport, you know that the Vaster Stein
distance is a distance between
probability distribution that regardless
of how far they are, is going to measure,
is going to give you this cost of optimal
transfer.
So the energetic cost of moving all that
pack of dirt from place A to place B in
the optimal way.
So the vaster shine distance is something
that we could use here.
But maximum mean discrepancy, it has a
lot of very nice properties and basically
reduced it to the Vaster Stein distance.
When we consider very close
distributions, this is not something that
just a mathematical curiosity, but it's
done that when one builds a distance out
of a divergence, what one does is one
takes very close distributions, measures
the divergence between them, at which
point the divergence is pretty much
symmetrical.
And then you basically keep adding
divergences along the trajectory until
you get to the final one.
And this way, by aggregating divergences
between very close distributions and
doing that and adding that along a
trajectory, you get a distance, a
meaningful distance between distributions
that could be very far.
If you do that with the Kale divergence,
you get what's called the fisher
information distance, which measures
really the amount of information that
took you from to go from one distribution
to another distribution, regardless of
how far they are.
If you do that with the vast search time
distance, you will get the optimal
transport cost.
So the amount of energy that you need to
put all that dirt, place A to place B in
the optimal way.
If you do that with the maximum
discrepancy, you would also get that you
will also get the optimal transport
thing.
I just want to say that the maximum
discrepancy discrepancy between two
distributions that are far away will not
coincide with the Vaster Stein distance,
which gives you this optimal transport
cost.
But when you actually derive a distance
from these divergences, the distance
derived from the maximum discrepancy and
the Vaster Stein distance will end up
being the same and the distance that you
actually get or the topology that is
derived from the distance.
So by topology, a topology is really a
notion of closeness.
And so to understand closeness, you need
to understand infinitesimal distances.
So the infinitesimal distances derived
from Vaster Stein or Mmd, they're the
same.
The topology that results is the topology
of what people call weak convergence,
which is a standard topology that's
considered in probability theory.
So Mmd and Vaster Stein, they are very
natural in that sense, in the sense that
people say that they met rise, weak
conversions, like they give rise to the
standard topology between probability
distributions.
So coming back to the choice of
divergences, if you're interested in
approximating distributions in the sense
of approximating their information
content, then KL is very natural.
But if you were for some reason and maybe
would not be in this kind of application,
but another kind of application, if for
some reason you're interested in
approximating distributions for the sake
of how close they are when you look at
them, then you wouldn't use Mmd or
Vassagetein.
Daniel: Wow, great information.
And I'm just thinking about we're
switching lanes on the highway we're
trying to get from here to there.
Yes, we want to know about the
informational closeness of this tale of
two densities, but we also want to know
about the transport closeness because we
have a schedule and a budget and
decisions to make, and there are trade
offs.
So being able to move the Earth optimally
while we're switching lanes and
accelerating and slowing down, I know
this is mixing many angles informally.
We want to have a lot of options for how
to think about that challenge of moving
dirt between the tail of two densities
and make sure everybody is driving in the
right lane at the right time.
Lance: Definitely, yeah, it's a design
choice and it's an important one because
it depends on what kind of properties we
want to preserve.
All these divergences, some are not so
useful, I guess, but some of them,
they're just very natural and vasterstein
and Mmd, they're very natural in that
sense.
Very important to keep in mind.
And not only active inference lab, but
just in general for any kind of inference
problem.
Daniel: Well, let us each have a closing
round or reflections, any thoughts or any
next steps or any suggestions or other
information you'd like to provide.
Lance: It's hard to say.
I feel we've covered so much already.
I think to me, what's most exciting about
is scaling active inference right now,
because you get this active inference
algorithm in the paper that's the right
compares principles and just from the
derivation, you see.
Okay, well, there's actually so many
things I dean, the assumptions are so
small that there are so many things that
you can model with this active inference
algorithm.
And all the heavy lifting is done by the
generative model.
So if you use one generative model, you
will get one behavior.
If you use another generative model, you
will get another behavior, but all the
equations will remain the same.
It speaks to the generality.
Now in having something that's very
general, you.
Get something that's also very non
specific.
And I guess for neuroscientists and
people who are interested in
intelligence, generality comes at a cost
of being non specific and non specific
about the brain in general.
So really the big question to me long
term is what kind of generative models do
we need to simulate brain like behavior?
Because this is really the interesting
behavior or the most interesting
behavior.
So it speaks to a big research program
that a lot of people are carrying and
have been carrying for a long time.
But it's about what kind of
representations do we have of the world?
What kind of priors do we have?
Can we identify the priors that we are
born with?
There's a lot of research on
computational or just playing cognitive
science, like normal cognitive science,
just studying babies and seeing what kind
of priors, what kind of basic information
they have when they come out of the
womb.
There's a lot of things that they can
already do there.
Our genetic code is preconditioning us to
operate efficiently in this world and be
able to flexibly adapt to any kind of
situations that might arise in the
natural world.
And so it's a huge research program to
understand and model these priors.
And not only the priors, but also the
likelihood, all the representation, all
the state spaces.
So I think that's the way forward.
The creation principle is very elegant
because it gives you a very succinct
description in terms of a giant model
that enables you to simulate pretty much
everything.
But we're not interested in simulating
anything.
We're interested in simulating brain like
behavior.
And now we need to drill down even more
onto the kind of Janitor models that
would be amenable to that.
Daniel: Great.
My closing reflection I feel like I know
less about fep, but more about something
else.
For what we've discussed.
Earth was moved, Bayesian mechanics were
called in, decisions were made, and it's
been a really great series.
So I'm appreciative and thankful that you
suggested this paper in our
correspondence as one to discuss.
You were absolutely right that it is
relevant to bring to the attention of the
active community.
And I hope that everybody who reads or
listens thus far has shifted lanes so
they can be where they want to be too.
Lance: Well, yeah.
Thank you so much.
I also really enjoyed the session and
think we had a really cool discussion.
So thanks again.
I hope to do this again soon.
Daniel: Excellent.
Anytime you'd like.
Very well.
See you, Lance.